i think what you said about the web one
concept is definitely true and you know
you see facebook changing the name to
meta
the metaverse according to bloomberg
standards should be like in
i think they said like an 800 billion
dollar industry by 2024 and i'm just
curious how twitter would be able to
kind of keep up in that kind of
direction i know that text will always
be relevant in that respect i just kind
of wonder it's it's less versatile i
wonder if it could start moving in that
direction if elon buys it and links it
up with the neural net maybe yeah yeah i
was going to say when i asked about the
town square thing immediately the first
thing that came to my mind was well
maybe it will be the metaverse and
especially if it's you know webb 2.0 or
whatever this is where you know we're
talking about like cops are
you know screaming at you that kind of
thing i'm imagining there was this well
i think it was wall street journal they
had one of their journalists go live in
the metaverse for 24 hours and she did a
youtube video about it she like they put
her in a hotel room and they gave her
food and she had to do like all of her
meetings she worked out she like went to
bars in it and she just lived in in it
and she had to deal with all of these
random people and was like oh my god
maybe that is the future of our social
media and so imagine what censorship
would be like in the
metaverse i was just gonna say there's a
it's something that truth theory on
instagram posted that there's a guy who
lived a week in the metaverse
he only had the goggles on
and uh he like he whatever like eat
everything and he said that there were
like amazing aspects to it because he
would go to like meditation class and he
was meditating for like an hour two
hours a day um but like there was parts
of it that were making him go insane in
his dream dreams were really messed up
because of it dude i had a dream three
nights ago where i was in a video game
but it was realistic it was like this
and in order to get through the part
that i was at i had to kill a dog in the
game you know like in warcraft world of
warcraft you have to fight dogs and
stuff and but it was real and it was a
little dog and they were like i was like
how do i do this they're like the most
humane way you know you gotta choke it
you gotta so i did in the dream and it
was so disturbing and now i'm thinking
about these people going into the vr
metaverse and they're gonna be killing
things like a video game but it's gonna
seem real what is that gonna do to
people talk about video games make
people violent yeah okay
disturbance i agree and disagree i i
think there there are going to be um
it's very different from playing a video
game with the controller while you're
watching a screen and you have some kind
of avatar or first person shooter you
know we've seen many studies the video
games don't cause violence they can
desensitize in other ways that can make
violence worse if you're prone to it i
think the real issue is that if if if
you're a regular person and you do
metaverse stuff i don't think you're
going to go around beating dogs but if
you're prone to these things then this
could exacerbate or at least desensitize
you and make you know the tendency to
divide a lot of video games maybe i
don't 90 80 percent of them are fighting
shooting
punching kicking
like if you get that and that's all of a
sudden all these people are jesus sorry
well i've i've done a deep dive there's
into the metaverse and welcome to the
metaverse these two podcasts i think
into the meta versus bloomberg specific
and like just going deep on like what is
this and a lot of people a lot of the
execs that they have they're like this
is huge but it's not like crypto it's
not something you just dump money into
you need to understand what it's here to
do and like why there are countries like
i think it was sweden that bought like
sizable real estate there for their
embassy and stuff like that so like you
don't have to go you can go and
kind of be in person but they're like
what they're really saying is like it's
not like a video game think
video games having to bend to meet the
internet so it's spatial web you're
interacting with the internet it's not
exactly like a video game so you're
right there's a lot of violence and
stuff like that there but this is gaming
meeting
virtual like internet stuff that you
would do to go and get paperwork done
and the one thing i was thinking about
when you were mentioning the dream
is the the technology that's coming out
potentially being able to give people
eyesight that is only virtual but
seeing something you know like hooking
it in
and they're seeing what they're seeing
like through camera they wear these
glasses in the same way that the heads
up displays mojo vision all the that
kind of stuff works but they're actually
seeing it through their vision so
there's things like that that i got i
got something for you you got you got
time for a project do some crazy yes get
a vr headset
bluetooth link it to a 360 camera
wear a backpack and have a 360 camera on
a monopod going up over your head have
the 360 degree view on your vr visor
screen and learn how to see in 360.
crazy yeah we we planned a pr with that
project a while ago but we we never
actually did it even though it's
extremely easy to do
but uh the idea is out there anybody who
wants to do it do it i've
i have mixed emotions but i think i
would do it yeah have you ever like in
school they they would put these like
mirrored glasses on to where you see the
world upside down and you would just
like throw a ball back and forth but you
wouldn't see it going up like this you
would see it coming down and up and it
was super weird but once you got the
hang of it it took like 15 minutes and
eventually you got the hang of it then
you take the glasses off
and you have to adjust again it takes
another 15 minutes to adjust back to the
normal way let me let me ask you bro
would you get the neural link and plug
your brain into a computer i don't think
so now
why not
i don't trust it i don't know i'm just
very
wary about all of it so i
was even though i you know live on
social media now for work i was raised
without television i did not barely
watch any movies growing up was not
allowed to play video games i was not
allowed to have social media until i was
you know 16 or something like that one
of the reasons why i wasn't on twitter
um just read a ton i was a classic
homeschooled kid um but i
i just don't really trust that and also
with the wasted part of neurolink where
they want to be able to like control
dopamine levels and like that kind of
thing i know that's part of it part of
it some of it is and it's like that
that's scary and it's like that
part of it i think there's something
that's interesting i think the
technology is fascinating and it's like
if you want to try go ahead i'm just not
going to really be your guinea pig i
think i trust myself more than i trust
technology
so that's the key right there is like
technology is doing something that it's
not that we can't do these things there
are ways but a lot of the times it's
like
what's the easiest way to do it take
take this pill and then forget about it
don't engage with your healing you know
well it reminds me of just everything
these days i feel like i look at the
world and it's like you can get your
groceries delivered to you every you can
have you can use an app and some
suddenly somebody's coming and like
hanging up something in your house like
everything is digitalized to the point
that it's like i could just stay never
leave my house and my life would
function on whether it would be like you
know wearing vr goggles being on zoom
like everything that feels very tactical
and real in the world
slowly being eroded in my eyes and then
add you know big pharma and we're just
medicating the crap out of my generation
there's i'm looking forward to the
psychedelic metaverse people are going
to be like heavily on psychedelics
they're making patches they're making
patches for just that so patches think
cocktails mdma ketamine
slight doses but you go in to have
whatever kind of experience you want to
have i think that's why psychedelics
have gone ipo like gangbusters lately
is
this idea of also where the metaverse is
going these fully immersive experiences
where
you like 1984 you almost don't revolt
against it it's it's servitude in a
sense but you don't revolt against it
because you have everything at your
disposal why get off the couch i was
thinking a new career might be like a
nanny metaverse nannies they make sure
you're fed and that you're able to poop
and pee and take it away for you make
sure your body's clean but they stay
there you can get robust this is so just
the distinction here is the current
metaverse is like you wear goggles
the future metaverse with the neural
link is you lay down in some kind of
sensory deprivation chamber floating and
you plug in your brain
and then all of a sudden your brain
experiences the metaverse
sometimes
about that where you're like in this
warm gooey liquid and you're hooked up
in the back of your head and
experiencing but
you every day
you know you wake up you go oh man what
a day and you're and check this out
you're ripped
you're as fit as fit can be no no no and
and you don't work out because when you
can plug your brain in it just control
controls stimulation so while you're
sitting in the metaverse your body's you
know just twitching and being programmed
to build this perfect lean body in every
way
you know processing the right nutrients
craving the right things or they just
plug in the feeding tube and you you put
it in your throat
and then plug yourself in and
and you don't
realize i wonder what would what would
the purpose of life then be if we were
just [ __ ] up to fight dragons
obviously what did you plug yourself in
and you're yes that's it what do you
think is the problem
what do you think is the purpose of life
productivity and work
more
more of an objectivist um would you say
about like literally
real quick just to what end to what end
like what did like how far would i go no
like like if if the point of life is
productivity and productivity and work
to what end is it just indefinite work
and creation or is it is there something
where you're going uh to leave the world
a better place than i started it or to
create something tangible um can it
always be better
like i think so within the realm of
physical creation shouldn't there be
some point where we're like it cannot
get any better than this or something
you know
maybe do you think that i don't know if
that's
possible because i feel like human
innovation is kind of difficult too i
suppose i suppose the thing is dude
if if we were to say like what's better
it would be people being well fed safe
good medical care and things like this
and better dwellings better living and
we've dramatically improved that thanks
to capitalism mind you and uh with the
metaverse one could argue that you'll
have everything you've ever wanted all
of those things but it's more like
heroin than it is actually making the
world a better place
you're starving you're you're frail and
shaking in the corner and you're like i
i don't want to go work man you just
plug me in the metaverse and then you
walk over and you're shaking you're like
super pale and then you plug your brain
in and then you flashes and you're
standing there six foot six super ripped
nba star and you're like yeah and you're
dunking
and people won't want to walk away or
it's good the haptic feedback is going
to make your muscles strong you'll be
able to live like six days in the span
of 20 minutes and you'll have all this
knowledge when you come out and you'll
be a superhuman
that's what we're in that way
like there's so much nuance with this
because like that's that's a possibility
for sure but i think that like what
we're talking about here is like what's
you were saying to what end and could
the value come from being hooked up to
the metaverse like imagine if 7.5
billion were hooked up to the metaverse
perhaps the planet would do better
you know perhaps some species would
would or the rate of extinction would
slow down but i also feel that like
humans when you had uh was it was it
michael knows
and jeremy uh no michael knowles and
jeremy boring were on last night okay
i thought sheamus was on he was also one
last night yeah oh okay yeah so so that
was the one that i was listening to when
you guys were having the would it be
better to save the dog with a cure for
cancer you know
i was thinking about all that and the
way that they were putting it is like we
i feel like we are here to engage with
what's already here and like to improve
upon it is debatable it's definitely
debatable but i definitely think that
like with
much of technology it's not that we've
been ripped from being able to to
acknowledge that
we have what we need here and a lot of
it is like if we were hooked up to the
metaverse would the planet actually be
doing better or would we be missing the
point well you know not every person on
the planet is destroying it so maybe
what we would need is some powerful
individual to create a system where we
can round up all of those that we deem
unfit and force them into the metaverse
i like this idea yeah you know and then
the world would be a better place once
those people are no longer allowed to uh
engage with it i think china would have
the stomach to do that right oh yeah and
then you know we could do like if
there's a pandemic we could weld
people's doors shut and seal them inside
until they starve to death yeah
something about these will be fine yeah
because okay that's a good point no
one's gonna want to be stuck and
imprisoned in the metaverse people like
any good slave they're going to want you
to want to be in it that's right brave
new world not 1984. it's like the world
economic forum thing where they're like
in 2030 you will own nothing you will
well what is that what are they going to
be creating
yeah that kind of thing that makes me
think of the metaverse but
that may be true
they say you will own nothing i think we
should correct that statement from the
world economic forum what they should
say is
you will own
the
dragon's bracers of ultimate power and
the sword the level 99 sword of
volcipheron nft and you'll be so stoked
this is the promise you only own a
license to the game that they give you
it in because if i get banned off steam
then i don't have access to any of those
games you'll own the nft you just won't
have a house clothes a car yeah grab
your pod though you'll have the floating
pot and the best part is
you don't have to eat the bugs no no
when you're in the metaverse the bugs
just flow through the feeding tube into
your gut and you've got to think twice
has anyone seen the uh the new blade
runner with ryan gosling no while ago
it's it's it's a glimpse jared leto's
role in that and what he's talking about
how like you know we lost our stomach
for slavery so now we started creating
the slaves like full-grown adults and
stuff like that soundtrack is dope in
that by the way too but like very
revealing the way they look at like kind
of the future of where commerce is going
and having like virtual sex slaves and
things along those lines i think blade
runner the one with ryan gosling is
kind of an eye opener people are going
to go insane from the metaverse because
you take a look at what's going on now
with kids and let's just try to be
family friendly adult content on the
internet being so
just uh
what's what's this pervasive pervasive
two-thirds of the internet the the
eclectic nature of it meaning like rule
thirty was it rule thirty four three
four is that the one where it's like if
there's if it exists there's porn of it
correct okay
so so the old rules the internet imagine
what happens when you're in the
metaverse and it's not just an image you
can look at but you can actually
experience and so the black mirror black
mirror did an episode about this where
the guy he goes into the video game
where he's a woman and he bangs a panda
people are going to go crazy because
they're going to get out and be like you
know i'd love to have a family with you
but i'm only attracted to clouds
it's like what what well in the
metaverse you can go up the cloud and
talk to it and do what you want to do
you know what i'm saying we're sort of
at that point with people in neo
pronouns like i was looking at a girl on
tick tock recently and she was like i
identify as like death death self and
plant plant self i mean there is like
yeah plant self
and it's we're already did you see
doll's self no
she like shaved her head and she's like
i am doll
horrified one eye like goes you know
it's up there with the furries yeah it's
it's worse yeah i mean look look i'm
fairly libertarian if i don't care if
people want to you know
dress up how everyone dress up or
metaverse what they want to do the point
is at a certain point people are going
to
they're going to segment away from
there's not going to be a cohesive
society yeah
that's my point
the problem is that kids are going to go
in and with haptic feedback full body
suits on so they can feel everything
they're experiencing and then someone
else is an old man is going to be in
there shaped as a cloud and he's going
to be like come here
and then the kid will go up and
basically have sex with this digital sex
with this other person and it's it's
going to warp because yeah they'll be
doing it with ai and interacting but it
won't be the same as with another human
on the other hand bro there's going to
be a predator in the game
and someone's going to meet it's going
to it's going to be a catfish dude
you're gonna be a 30 year old straight
guy in the metaverse and you're gonna
meet this you know attractive young
blonde woman and you're gonna do the
haptic feedback stuff and it's gonna
it's gonna turn out to be like a 63 year
old morbidly obese man who's like yeah
yeah that's right young man i think this
is where the the identity fluidity is
coming in i definitely believe that it
if not intentional it's working towards
the what you can become in the metaverse
in the metaverse there's already been
like um i don't know if it was straight
rape because it didn't have the
functionality in the game to do it but
harassment like several guys coming up
and cornering a girl and just not
letting her out that's what's happening
like you can block someone in the
metaverse
you should call it metaverse cops
hold on hold on i mean like you just you
know you go like this you go
i'm for those that are listening i'm
motioning my hands taking the goggles
off it's not working and then you're
like but i had to take my goggles off
and i didn't want to yeah against my
will or you just like you just click the
button that teleports you to the other
room
that that could be another one but like
a lot of what i think this is doing when
you were saying the haptic suits and as
i was saying with the patches that can
modulate hormones as well as terrell
mcsweeney i think she worked under
barack obama she's now talking about the
internet of bodies and how
they're like the it's how's it going to
get classified is it going to be
something where if you have a handicap
you can fix it by getting your eyesight
back or is it an upgrade and then once
it goes that far they've already talked
about if you're a sex offender and this
was i think in 2016 terrell mcsweeney
was or 2017 she was talking about this
you you can have one of these implants
that can lower your uh create more
inhibition against some of those drives
of sexual predators so then
then they had to start getting into well
are they allowed to have those drives
what about
prison
and what prison is let's imagine we get
to the point where neural link is a plug
in your brain right because elon musk's
already done done that with the pigs
where they put the electrodes let's say
we get to the point where you actually
have a port
and it's wireless you can wirelessly
connect to the metaverse let's say
you're a
child predator you get convicted and so
they say we're sentencing you to 15
years in the metaverse
but
in the metaverse
it's a mundane existence where you can
never act upon any of these urges and
you're internal in your own basically
virtual prison
your body is being programmed to do
menial labor so the prison sentence is
your body is just what can i get for you
today we have a double cheeseburger on
the menu in your mind your conscious
self is trapped in this metaverse
reality which is a prison that's like a
handmaid's tale oh yeah i'm also scared
that about time warping in the game so
or in the metaverse not a game uh that
where it will literally feel like 15
years of your life but it's only 20
minutes like inception
and they can just
snap you in and you're like or you could
even do it to yourself you're like i
want to live a life and you do it and
it's like when you come back you barely
even remember your your friends when you
come back there's a there's a show about
that we mentioned it i can't remember if
it was a show or a movie where this guy
invents the like eye drops and that
connect they can make their nanobots
that can pro they're programmed to make
you experience a certain amount of time
so
the original idea is like it's a you
drop it in your eye and then you're in a
ski trip and so it's like in the blink
of an eye you have a weekend in you know
aspen but then this the guy's like i
want to turn into a prison and so he
makes like a 50-year sentence or
whatever something like that and then
you know this woman gets trapped in it
or something i don't like that's crazy i
think you might be referring to an
episode of black mirror
yeah there was some guys who were up
north and one of these like um like an
arctic um
fort or something and they realized that
they were not actually in reality
because they couldn't go outside they
couldn't do anything they were like oh
my god no it's a different movie i'm
talking about and there was a lady who
got stuck in it she was like screaming
trying to get help and she it felt like
years and years had passed and it had
been like 10 minutes or something that
is one of the most horrifying things to
me the idea of being able to get people
to believe that it's been a really long
time kind of a rip van winkle effect
it's like insane like i really don't
like the direction this could go like
who knows how we could psychologically
torture people i think it's called other
life
interesting
do you remember when i was talking about
the fourth turning the first time i came
on and it was like during a crisis
period the most advanced weapons of war
uh are used what you just explained
lydia
seems it to me like you know
torture on the deepest psychological
level then getting back to the prison
thing what's interesting is is like you
know prison
at least it has this you know um
attempt in the title of being a
rehabilitation facility right could
something like that actually get more
targeted into rehabilitation because i
know that i think it was in
not nevada it might have been arizona
there was a prison where they just
decided to dress all the inmates in pink
paint all the walls pink and it lowered
crime incredibly yeah
and then there's there's this other one
in thailand when i was out there
training uh in muay thai
where you could actually fight your way
out and their world champion champion
fought his way out of prison you could
actually fight it out really like in
batman when they're like if you can
climb out you're free yeah yeah and this
guy did he became world champ and then
dave leduc a canadian came in and
whooped his ass and baron bare knuckle
boxing wow but like i think there's more
we could do prison wise to not make it
the like what prison does to people i
think you could probably get more
intelligent with what you said using the
metaverse or whatever maybe plant
medicine something like that yeah you
just can't force people to do
plant medicine you know at least morally
you know administrate psychedelics to
prisoners you mean ayahuasca you know
how many people have these life ex
life-changing experiences under right
guidance um the wrong guidance it could
be the worst thing what if we start
programming prisoners
what if you know uh
we get to this point where
such bad things happen in our society
we just say you know what it is better
that we neurolink or you know program
the brain
instead of sending them to prison we
like you were mentioning with child
predators we wire their brain in a way
so that they cannot act on certain
issues impulses or whatever you know
what i mean like
turn off the aggression turn off
attraction because they haven't don't
they already chemically castrate some
people
do they do that i believe so yeah could
be wrong about that maybe i was a movie
not in every in every i i think i've
heard of that in countries i know that i
heard that recently people in ukraine
saying like if we capture russians we're
going to castrate them but yeah that's
that's like a threat of like
defensiveness and war is what i mean
do they do this because this may be just
some like fictional idea where
a sex offender gets you know
pills so that they can't
those child predators yeah is that i
think so let me look it up i feel like i
saw but i think that's interesting
because like think about like
a lot of people say well prison like
people don't commit some crime some
people don't commit crimes
for the threat of what might happen
so like imagine the threat of a neural
link in your brain where all those urges
go away and it's it's not up to you
anymore what if i mean man
neural link is some scary stuff man
because i don't think we even understand
how terrifying it can be it's not going
to be wired it's going to be wireless
why would they why would you need a
wired cable no it's going to wi-fi
connect to your brain and then someone's
going to hack your brain and make you
experience some crazy
stuff
and then what happens if someone hacks
your brain and then you're you're
feeling like you're being attacked by
ninjas and you're really just beating
the crap out of strangers
you know
the lack of control is just
probably the most horrifying thing i
think social media is like the early
adoption of that the way people can be
twisted just by media well i was even
thinking with like metaverse stuff like
we've seen especially with gen z and you
know my generation that's grown up with
social media just like are all like our
slew of mental health issues and the way
that we are desensitized to basically
everything uh and the way that we
function
is so drastically different than other
generations i mean you look at um did a
business program at berkeley before i
graduated and we had this whole class on
like corporate psychology and it was all
of these hr departments at huge orgs
prepping for gen z because they're like
you're so sensitive you are you know we
have to basically rework our entire
structure to prep for this generation
that has been you know royally screwed
by social media so it's like if that is
just what has happened with you know
instagram twitter and tick tock
like what the hell is going to happen
but the reason i asked you earlier how
you felt about it was because
i think what will end up happening the
metaverse will not be popular at first
some people will get it for necessity
because it'll be easier to work when
you're using the metaverse and it'll
probably start with a headset eventually
they'll make some kind of simple eeg
interface eventually some people will
opt to get some kind of like wireless
implant
when the young people are entering the
workforce
it's going to be normal people are going
to do it
it's not going to be an issue of whether
you think it's weird or creepy it's
going to be like oh but you know
everyone does it well i wonder is how
much uh diet plays a role because you
were saying before the show that you're
keto or you've been keto for a while
yeah this is beautiful and helped clean
up the mine yeah i found like cleansing
the gut biome and i wonder it's hard to
to measure like how much of it is these
microplastics or you know estrogen in
the water or like have you studied this
stuff ben i know you look into this
stuff from time to time is it
quantifiable how much diet has
impacted the youth in addition to social
media because i for a long time just
thought it's got to be social media it
has to be and like i mean it's such a
nuanced question because look at our top
soil and now look at our microbiomes
like the microbiome of the earth is
eroding there's like the amount of
supplementation you need to have the
microbiome naturally that our ancestors
had
is is going to cost you a lot of money
you you can't do it on low or minimum
wage so that's just the microbiome and
then you're adding on top of it the the
pcbs the micro plastics
whatever else is in there i'm hearing a
lot about graphene you know and stuff
like that even in water supplies so
there's things that we can account for
things that we can account for and then
there's sedentary lifestyle which is
huge so like there was this guy steven
jepsen 80 years old never leave the
playground.com and he was taking people
over the age of 65
and um because past 65 if you break your
hip your mortality rate goes through the
roof he was just doing things like two
buckets in front of them
bare feet picking up objects like
marbles and tacks with your toes and
dropping it into the other bucket
that would like work on the talus and up
here and it would actually they would
notice that it was halting
neurodegenerative disorders like or
diseases like parkinson's alzheimer's
stuff like that and then like making it
trickier like you stick you have to
stand up and do it stuff like that is
important for the brain it turns
neurology back on it promotes
neurogenesis and neuroplasticity
and that's just what we can quantify so
like it's a whole new playing field
because the like everything from the
soil to the way we sit all day long and
as you were saying like a very sedentary
lifestyle and we've gotten to the point
where we don't need to get up anymore
and the metaverse is going to exacerbate
that so it's really it's those who want
to engage with health and decide that
i'm not going to wait for somebody else
to do it for me i need to do it for
myself and that's huge especially with
like the pharmaceutical conversation
where it's like
i mean you can look at how many kids in
the last 20 25 years have suddenly been
diagnosed with add adhd or any other
mental health thing and so you just
throw
any drug on top of them rather than
addressing what is your lifestyle what
are you eating are you even going
outside how much time are you spending
online it's like sure here take these
meds that kind of thing we're just
royally screwing up our bodies but
they're very natural and this isn't like
some hippie holistic whatever it's like
no we have
it's very new that we have just been you
know throwing these things on our brains
and right it's it's new
literally the technology the pills the
chemicals didn't exist depending on
which medicine 10 20 30 40 50 years ago
yeah hormones were isolated i think what
the beginning of the 1900s and estrogen
was in the 60s high fructose corn syrup
aspartame in the early 80s like that
stuff's relatively super low all this
weird stuff we're doing the fact that
you have to say this food is organic
over here like we're going to label it
as organic is strange because now look
at the ratio of organic to non-organic
in in
stores like the fact that you have to
label it like that means that everything
else is not and it probably has things
in that that will affect you
neurotransmitters all the way down to
the hormones so like it's it's a lot and
you were just talking about like well
you said adhd but like autism yeah we we
laugh at simple approaches to these
things and we applaud pharmaceutical
like um profit based ones whereas if you
speak to somebody with autism in a
prosodic voice meaning kind of lilting
poetic up and down it halts in its
tracks the uh the symptoms of autism
almost completely and this was steven
porgis polyvagal theory just the way you
speak to them is different they stop
staring at your mouth and they start
staring at your eyes symptoms go away
and that's that's just one of many
things
and and what do we we don't get into
that conversation because just let the
you know the pharmaceutical companies
take care of that that's the narrative
it's the same with schizophrenia and
that sort of thing we have a very good
family friend of ours who runs a
fantastic non-profit and he is a
schizophrenic but he has completely
controlled his voices i think he also
has ocd i'm pretty sure he's bipolar as
well multiple personality disorder that
kind of thing he had a whole slew of
trauma when he was younger
um was in jail many many many times
completely turned it around is now fully
in control of his voices runs two
businesses and his non-profit and is
totally like carnivore and is but it's
all based on lifestyle and he's totally
off meds and it is wild to see how those
very simple i mean you have to be very
you know
committed to those lifestyle choices but
the power that you have as an individual
to make those changes to not be you know
at the beck and call of a
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
pm and don't forget to smash that like
button subscribe to this channel and if
you want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you